c'est les dix ans de la mort de claude
françois et maintenant sachant mais pas
non c'est l'anniversaire
c'est l'anniversaire de la mort de
claude françois serrés à 40 ans 33 merci
dans l'oreillette je vous emmerde arrêté
de reprendre tout le temps si 10 33 32
je fais ce que je veux chez le médecin
merde donc si les 18 ans de la mort d'un
village
c'est l'anniversaire de la mort de
claude françois et pour lui rendre
hommage on a pris les meilleurs sosies
on applaudit françois on à johnny
hallyday et cki troisième
on attaque mais éclatez vous lever vous
que françois musique
bonsoir
sa vie
cette année-là
châtel pour la première fois
[Musique]
cette année là comme arrivant le public
déjà
mais il tarde que je décore une rançon
doha le bas
b
[Musique]
ma chanson glissé pages tout droit
[Applaudissements]
chacun gardera
kick ass et le bon câble puis j'y pense
c'est moins joli
[Musique]
ces petits
changer
c'est ma maman qui se savait comment
c'était
[Applaudissements]
72 heures
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que tu te rappelles que vous
pourrez graines de tpm people match
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc
et khartoum
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
wade
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci
merci c'est pas terminé la course que
vous êtes là c'est toi
rappelons que la renault 5 immatriculé
air 12 503 où est garée devant le local
à poubelles on continue maintenant avec
le troisième et le troisième c'est qui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
l'amour est
[Musique]
élevé
[Applaudissements]
et bien comme un espoir à morges demain
je meurs chaque soir
mais je veux partager autre chose que
l'amour
[Applaudissements]
d'entendre une plume et souplesse ou
s'écrit tous ensemble
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
james
je m'appelle part ça tous ensemble j'ai
rempilé
[Musique]
les amis
m
ça lui a
été attribué par mois
plus un plaisir tu sais que lui
soit pour toi chaud pour michael pour te
franchement je deviens toi ta prestation
pour s'installer et surtout est ce que
tu sais que si tu étais parti quinze
minutes plus tôt qui sera arrivé quinze
buts o
[Applaudissements]
françois
michael
redonner le goût
alors là vous dira sur les réseaux
sociaux parce que j'ai aucune idée mais
franchement je peux vous dire que donc
comme françois c'est laurent peyrac
bravo bras
6-4 en 11 mars aux chambres 18 cas et
vous vous retrouve partout en france et
nous on en retrouve partout en france
exactement 6 mais j'ai envie d'aller
brasse mais il faut veiller on vous
invite à mais je voulais vois-tu mrsk
pas une tournée de sosies
berisha méditerranée on tourne tous les
étés on fait tout
ça dépend il ya des plateaux des fois et
des fois on est en soliste ça dépend
c'est génial de voir ça abbas que je
sais la tête de jean michel quand les
clodettes centre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fait connaître au coeur
j'ai vu jean michel
des manières forever prépare l'émission
mais même il avait une façon dans
cet assassinat
mais vraiment bravo merci monsieur un
johnny et bien c'était johnny vegas
j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour ce que
vous faites à prix reçus mais michael
jackson vous êtes arrivé en loge
monsieur dit bon bah c'est sûr un
charmant monsieur cayla et une fois
maquiller c'est là qu'on voit les vrais
artistes tout d'un coup c'est max
[Applaudissements]
mj lille mjn m6 il a beau dire est le
nom d'un truc de sport cdes à lyon les
initiales plus mon prénom lille mon
prénom c'est dénier tous les trois ans
qu'on peut vous retrouvez à la world
company trouvez-vous avec à la prod
vous tapez à la pruderie nous viennent
de la prod ils viennent tous deux à
prendre vraiment nous a donné les
meilleurs les meilleurs du web
j'avais juste une petite question pour
michael jackson parce que michael
jackson était surtout connu pour son
gant en strass si vous n'êtes que des
pansements c'est une question de
la hausse était juste pour femmes
embrouillé et ça c'est quand même que
quand on a préparé l'émission et c'est
pas une blague on a dû aux chroniqueurs
qui souhaitez-vous voir isabelle morini
bosc a dit charles trenet
mathieu si je me permettre c'est vrai
que notre ami jackson le violon tout à
l'heure à la propre qui vous a mis en
contact avec nous donc merci de votre
invitation avec qui on travaille
régulièrement tout au long de l'année et
nous sommes sur tout le bassin
méditerranéen ont pas de coolio donc on
est sur argelès sur mer canet plage au
bord de la mer avec du soleil on va
jusqu'à la côte d'azur ont fait 44 45
gallas surtout les yuppies rédac pour
confier au cap d'agde avec deux skoda
je sais pas sur la musique mais comme il
reste six minutes avant la pub et après
on a un gros sujet sur la grossophobie
donc rien à voir ouais est ce que tu
peux me faire un magnolia for ever ou
pas
bien sûr
sur la grossophobie est-ce qu'on a une
musique long comme sa musique à celle-ci
ou a cappella ce musicien ils sont
foulés claudel on est samedi
[Applaudissements]
et
vous
[Applaudissements]
je suis quand même
dit annick je suis
déjà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un pub apprête à venoix
je ne veux plus rien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ne sais plus comment faire
[Applaudissements]
s'il savait que
ma
le charme
la chanson
qui parmi elle dit